hannah herzlich willkommen in meiner
taten welt ich habe heute die auflösung
führen dem gewinnspiel für euch aber als
zuerst erzähle ich euch wieso ich erst
heute das gewinnspiel auslöse ich habe
gesagt entweder freitagabend oder
samstag
aber freitagabend ging nicht weil ich
wie ihr hinter mir sehen könnt drei
taten zubereitet habe eine verlobung
torte für meine freundin eine torte für
einen freund und eine hochzeitstorte für
einen freund und princess haben ihre hat
mir natürlich fleißig geholfen und die
letzten zwei tage oder beziehungsweise
die letzte woche habe ich komplett
gebacken also ich mag schon seit sonntag
bis samstag also insgesamt sieben tage
an diesen torten mit den figuren und mit
dem kremstal hallo und mein mann hat
dann gestern abend nichts anderes
gemacht als eure kommentare auszuwerten
und dann die gewinner eben zu verkünden
es waren über 4000 kommentare und
natürlich kann nicht jeder gewinnen bei
4.000 kommentaren aber ich habe sieben
ausgelost und habe jetzt hier auch die
namen und wartet dann einfach die
päckchen dazu auslösen und das einzige
paket oder das einzige geschenk was
schon feststeht ist dass glutenfrei und
ich würde sagen ich verkünde es einfach
die gewinner das glutenfreie päckchen
hat gewonnen von facebook gabi entner
wolfgang und dir gehört dieses päckchen
ich liebe dich auch das macht ist es
okay ich sage jetzt gleich noch vorweg
die die bei facebook gewonnen haben
lassen wir bitten den pinnwand eintrag
auf meiner chronik dann weiß ich wie ich
euch kontaktieren kann und die die auf
youtube gewonnen haben sollen bitte auf
youtube mir eine nachricht schreiben
wenn sie nicht wissen wie das geht
einfach einen kommentar unter dem video
hinterlassen
und dann so wie ich euch einfach nur mal
und kontaktiert so als nächstes habe ich
ein gewürz päckchen und samira gib mir
eine gewinnerin oder ein
gewinner von youtube auch elia barbie
herzlichen glückwunsch
nachts ein gewinn stechen gewonnen
nochmal ein gewürz päckchen für dieses
jahr hinaus facebook das ist für dich
dann 1 25 euro baloise mikro dann findet
die 20 euro gutschein aus meinem shop
da wäre es natürlich noch ein
gutscheincode eintragen und für dich
signieren und zwar für keine corinna
schuster aus facebook letzte woche habe
ich übrigens über 1000 gutscheine
unterschrieben für den shop und die
könnt ihr online natürlich auch sallys
shop bestellen falls ihr jemanden
beschenken wollte der zweite gutschein
geht an super zauberhaft von youtube
herzlichen glückwunsch
das vom band starterset hat gewonnen
die nati anna doria aus facebook
herzlichen glückwunsch und mein back
starterset mit den ganzen sachen die
hier unten jetzt stehen trotz gewonnen
wird will alles von youtube hat und wie
gesagt dürft ihr euch einfach per
youtube oder per facebook bei mir melden
so wie es aussieht weil es bei 150000
größeres gewinnspiel machen müssen
zum beispiel mit einer küchenmaschine
und die videos zu den torten hinter mir
die kommen natürlich jetzt jeden sonntag
und wir wünschen euch noch einen ganzen
tag bis bald ein teil meiner torten
wurde zum abgeholt übrigens wurde ich
das kann auf instagram gefragt ob ich
die torten auf bestellung mache das
mache ich nicht
also das war jetzt auch nur für meine
freunde ich verkaufe keine torten wenn
ihr sowas machen wollt müsst ihr euch da
gut informieren müsse auch ein gewerbe
anmelden das geht ja nicht einfach so
dass man torten macht und einfach
verkauft sondern man muss es ja dann
gewerblich machen und wie gesagt mache
ich das nur für meine freunde ich
verschenke meine torten und macht es
auch echt nur in extremen ausnahmefällen
ich war noch kurz sagen seid bitte nicht
traurig weil jetzt nicht gewonnen habt
natürlich kann ich von 100.000 leute
nicht hunderttausend leute gewinnen
lassen so viele gewinner hatte ich gar
nicht und vielen dank fürs mitmachen und
für style in meiner videos vielen dank
dass ihr immer meine videos teilt und
immer kommentiert ich gestolpert und ja
einfach herzlichen dank auch für die
bewertungen immer und ich freue mich
einfach auf ganz viele weitere videos
auf weitere 100.000 abonnenten und ja
danke die prinzessin eine echte
prinzessin sein